[Music]
oh
the scottish claymore
the claymore was used by scottish
mercenaries in battle from the 15th to
17th century
the weapon usually 55 inches in length
would have to be held with both hands
and swordsmen were unable to carry a
shield
symbolizing fearlessness on the
battlefield
the klansmen would swing the sword in
figure eight movements
decapitating and dismembering
adversaries
legend has it that scottish knight
william wallace used to claymore in the
war for scottish independence this epic
weapon has been immortalized in the
classic movie braveheart
bladesmiths this is the kill test
the term claymore in gaelic means great
sword to see how lethal your weapon is
and to test its functionality according
to its historic design i will deliver
two killing blows on this animal carcass
scott you're up you ready i'm ready
let's do it
i see the pigs and i'm thinking oh crap
i've cut tests against pigs and they
don't cut very easily at all
oh
the moment doug hits the pig and i hear
that thud
i'm like crap
uh scott we have a little problem here
the hardness of your blade
is a little bit on the uh flexible side
it did not even cut the carcass
so that brings into question also
the sharpness of your edge
i think and we're pretty much done
congratulations
it will not kill
this is a failure
jonathan you're up are you ready
absolutely
i'm confident that i made a good blade
the blade is hard and it's ready to cut
this is gonna be spectacular
oh boy
[Music]
jonathan we have a major blade
malfunction
it did initially cut through
but then it probably hit the spine
it just exploded
i'm not completely confident that i'm
gonna come out with the wind here but
my blade cuts
and that's more than scott's
jonathan your blade suffered
catastrophic failure for safety reasons
we can no longer continue testing on
your blade
since both weapons have suffered
malfunctions
dave will now decide on the best course
of action to move forward with the
competition
dave in the viking sagas swords broke
and the song of roland's swords broke
but bent swords can be straightened
so we'd like to give you an opportunity
scott to straighten that weapon so we
can take it forward into a sharpness
test
to help us determine our winner
so scott why don't you take a moment and
straighten your weapon okay
that's as straight as it's going to get
now not only was the claymore a
battlefield intimidator but it was also
a scottish symbol for physical prowess
and strength so what i'm going to do to
test the edge of your blade is i am
going to cut into this piece of sheet
steel
so scott are you ready let's do it
[Music]
i've got a 50 50 shot that it's going to
do well you know i just want to see what
happens
i am desperate to win this 10 000 on the
line here
i don't even want to watch
[Music]
[Music]
well scott
there's actually still an edge here
we can see what it did to the steel
should have the pig made out of steel it
probably would have cut better
all in all well done thank you overall
i'm pleased this was the first time i've
ever made a blade of this size of this
complexity
gentlemen this by far was our most
difficult challenge to date
congratulations you both delivered
your scottish claymores
but there can only be one champion
scott
congratulations you are the forest and
fire champion thank you
thanks jonathan unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut
jonathan the design of your blade was
really going in the right direction
basically once that blade snapped it
just wasn't anything else we could do to
test that blade so that's why we're
letting you go jonathan please surrender
your way
it's great man thank you sir
i'll be back
absolutely proud of myself with every
failure there's a great lesson learned
and i think i'm moving forward from here
scott congratulations you are the force
to fire champion and you'll be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
i've never won anything in my life this
is the first time i've ever won anything
you try your best and you learn from it
and then you do it again until you
perfect it
and even though the sword didn't do what
i wanted it's still okay i won
i'm certainly going to be buying drinks
tonight
[Music]
a cutlass
army hearties we get to make a cutlass
i'm very excited about it
the cutlass is a short broad-bladed
saber developed in europe during the
16th century
although it was made as a land weapon it
was quickly adopted as the sailor's
weapon of choice largely because it was
strong enough to hack through ropes
canvas and wood but also because it was
short enough to use in close quarters
combat
this made it popular amongst navies
throughout the world the last use of the
cutlass and boarding action by the
british royal navy was recorded as late
as 1941.
its effectiveness in battle also made
the cutlass favorite amongst pirates as
portrayed in the film franchise the
pirates of the caribbean
gentlemen the cutlass was a weapon that
was specifically designed for naval
combat but was just as effective on land
now any pirate that went raiding would
probably run into a situation where he
needed to work his way through a
barricade
so to test the strength of your weapons
we're gonna break our way through these
crates
tobin you're up
let's do this
when i saw
the crates
the only thing i could think of was
those poor crates
[Music]
well tobin it's got a lot of weight to
it
it's a quite a heavy beast i like the
blacksmith guard nice but
it's so long that your hand has a lot of
room to travel in here
a bit of deformation and a couple of
chips in the blade okay
but
tobin this will definitely break through
a barricade
good job
thanks
ron
you're up next let's do it
going to the weapons test it's
nerve-wracking but i'm hoping everything
works out it should have the weight on
it to do the chopping
so ron
though your handle was very crude it was
actually pretty comfortable
your blade shows no chipping
no damage it's a little on the heavy
side but it didn't feel like it was
pulling me forward i was able to control
the tip
but uh all in all
went through some crates
to test the sharpness of your weapon i
will take your weapon and cut through
fish and then rope
tobin you're up
let's do it i'm ready
well tobin
it's sharp enough to cut through the
fish
it lacerated through the rope
but it didn't cut all the way through
i hear the chunk of the blade go
right through the fish and then i hear
it hit the ground
why did he not cut the rope
i it's
a little bit of disbelief about that
ron you're up next
go for it
[Music]
well ron
definitely lacerated the fish but it
didn't slice all the way through your
edge really isn't that sharp to cut all
the way through
ron's blade doesn't go through the fish
but it cuts the rope
huh
late schmidts this is the kill test i
will take your cutlass and deliver
offensive strikes to this ballistic
dummy then we can see how much damage
your cutlass will deliver
tobin you're up
[Music]
that cut right through the chest
a laceration into the pectoral muscle
right here
[Music]
not much on this slash here
but
that's all the way through
it will kill
ron you're up next you ready i'm ready
ron
there are no visible marks
unfortunately
your blade will not kill
i'm completely shocked there's no damage
on the dummy
tobin ron
you were both given five days at your
home forge
to create signature cutlasses to perform
in our final round of testing
doug
ron the balance of your blade allowed me
to move around in a fluid motion it's
got good balance for recovery as well
but a cutlass is a thrust and slash
weapon and one test just didn't perform
that way
tobin i love the edge geometry of your
blade
it's got good flats and a good thin
taper that allowed it to cut well but i
would have liked to have seen that blade
and height reduced by about a third i
think you would have got a better heat
treat and would prevent it the chipping
on the edge of your blade
bladesmiths you've both done commendable
work
and it's time for one of you to leave
the forge
and one of you to be declared the forged
and fire champion
tobin congratulations you were the
forest empire champion
thank you
ron
your blade did not make the cut ron we
pushed your blade hard and held its edge
through the strength test but in the end
a cutlass
has to be a cut and thrust sword
and in the kill test
it just didn't perform
please surrender your weapon
thank you ron thank you i'm not bitter
towards tillman i'm not bitter tons of
anybody i had a great experience
lesson that i learned today is to keep
the blend shop
toby
congratulations
you are the forged and fire champion and
you will be receiving a check for ten
thousand dollars
how do you feel man how do you feel
uh dude there's no words like ah
nothing's coming up
freaking one yeah
i'm in shock a little bit i like the
overall look of your blade i like the
whole dark factor i like to sweep to it
i really like the edge geometry on it
it's just strange it's
i never win
anything
the fact that i want this i'm
i need a nap
[Music]
the scottish claymore
play more
joy this massive two-handed sword was
wielded by scottish highlanders as early
as 1490. made famous in modern pop
culture by the film braveheart its
impressive size and length made it a
fearsome weapon the claymore is easily
recognizable by its quatrefoil cross
guard and angled arms due to its large
size the heavy sword was usually swung
with two hands it was so deadly it was
nicknamed the slaughter sword by the
english who faced it on the battlefield
because of its prowess the claymore was
a mainstay of the scottish army for
nearly two centuries well bladesmiths
your weapons will now be subjected to
three tests
first up is the strength test as you can
see we've brought back a test worthy of
a champion's blade
bullet splitting
each of your blades will be locked into
a vise then we'll fire a single round at
your blades to test their edge retention
and strength if your weapons are strong
should split the bullet no problem
if they're not strong well your blade
could shatter entirely
good luck matt you're up first
[Music]
i'm feeling pretty good about my sword
it's exactly the same heat treat i did
last time and it held up perfectly fine
three two
one engage
nice
you got a couple little dimples on the
edge there just a little bit dulled but
everything held up beautifully good job
matt thank you
ben you're up are you ready
sure let's do it
let's get her ready
i can hear my heartbeat
it's terrifying i just don't want this
thing to snap into
three two one engage
nice there we
go yeah that sucker just fragmented he's
got a lot more profile than blaine
well ben
the only problem i could see is uh
rubbed a little bit of your etch off did
nothing at all to the blade edge is
still perfect thank you
all right next up is the sharpness test
and i'm gonna hand you over to dave for
that
gentlemen the scottish claim war as you
know was a brutal weapon on the
battlefield so to test the sharpness of
your blades i'm gonna take a single blow
through both these front legs of the
horse simulated with sugar cane if your
blades are sharp they should pass right
through
matt you're up are you ready yeah kill
the horse
[Music]
matt this weapon is so amazingly light
and flexible as well
that when i hit there was no resistance
it literally passed right through the
legs i was through them before i knew it
well done matt really well done
ben you ready let's do it all right
let's give it a try
matt made a light thin blade it cut
through the sugar cane like it wasn't
even there my blade is a little heavier
i'm pretty nervous that i might get
stuck but
we'll see
[Music]
he's still down yeah well ben it cut
cleanly through the first leg
kind of bogged down in the second leg
unlike mats and i have a feeling it's
the width of the profile up here
just slowing it down a bit
but i don't think that horse is running
ever again
nicely done bill
next up is the kill test for that i'm
going to hand you over to doug
bladesmiths this is the kill test to see
how lethal your blades are i will take
your claymore and i will try to cut
through these pig carcasses with one
chop
as you know last season both claymore
suffered catastrophic failures on this
very test let's see how much lethal
damage your blades can do
mat you're up first are you ready go for
it let's do this
[Music]
didn't break that's important
matt
i love the feel of your blade
it feels very comfortable in the hands
it's very easy to maneuver it was sharp
enough to cut through
in terms of lacerating but it's just so
flexible it didn't go through
for this test sir
it will not kill
i'm pissed at that pig right now
ben you're up next you ready hope so
let's do this
[Music]
ben this blade just sliced all the way
through that carcass
it's flexible
it's got a good feel to the cut
this sir
will kill thanks
good job
all right bladesmiths you've given the
judges a lot to talk about we're gonna
have to go back to the forge and
deliberate we'll see you there
thank you
matt ben welcome back the judges have
evaluated your weapons performance and
construction it was difficult but
they've made their final decision before
i continue they have something they'd
like to say to both of you doug
ben from the fit and finish of your
blade the gold inlays to the beautiful
pattern damascus that's razor sharp it's
only highlighted with its performance of
strength in the kill test it cut right
through way in the past that big carcass
has destroyed blades well done thank you
very much
jay
matt you're our very first fortune fire
champion ever and you keep bringing us
that championship quality and especially
in this piece i mean every aspect of it
is beautiful
that steel and that blade is just
incredible having a blade that size
flexing 90 degrees plus and coming back
to true
that's just amazing
gentlemen both of your weapons are
bulletproof they're sharp and they're
deadly but today there can only be one
forged and fire champion
ben congratulations you are our first
two-time forged and fire champion great
job
matt unfortunately your claymore did not
make the cut matt your claymore it's
fabulous to wield only issue was the
flex was so great that it didn't
transfer the energy into the target and
that's the reason you're going home
matt i have to ask you to surrender your
scottish claymore
i'm a fortune fire champion
that's never gonna go away i don't feel
like i failed in this i don't feel like
i'm a loser in this or anything i just
feel like
ben did slightly better and that's
awesome
ben
you are our first and only two-time
forged and fire champion we'll also be
receiving that check for 10 grand your
claymore is a thing of beauty not only
to look at but to wield
i'm a loss for words thank you very much
oh my god
i am the fortune fire champion of
champions i can't believe it the people
i was competing against are so good to
actually come out and win this thing
it's absolutely amazing
[Music]
the cat's bulger
introduced during the renaissance in the
late 15th century the cats bulger became
the main sidearm for european soldiers
known as lanchnicks a dominant military
force these soldiers defended the holy
roman empire in times of unrest designed
for close hand-to-hand combat the cat's
vulgar was often shorter than other
broadswords but quick and efficient in
action
soldiers wielded these weapons in deadly
ambushes using devious tactics to lure
the enemy into fatal attacks
its sturdy build and broad sharp blade
made it a powerful chopper while its
signature s-shaped guard was
instrumental in defense
gentlemen this is the strength test a
smith's nightmare
so what we'll do is we'll take your
blades we'll lock them into our vise
over here and fire one round from this
pistol now if your blade's strong it
should just split that bullet
if not we could have a blade shatter
james you're up first you ready ready
okay i'm pretty nervous maybe bullet
slice puts a lot of stress on a very
small part of the blade so you need to
have your heat treatment spot on or it's
going to cause some catastrophic
shattering of the blade three
two
one
fire
[Music]
the blade is still intact i can't see
any damage so we're good to this point
you can actually see
where it left a little bit of that
bullet on your blade
there's the tiniest deformation
other than that everything's still
together
good job nicely done all right paul it's
your turn you ready i'm ready okay
someone's gonna shoot my blade with a
gun i mean that's you don't do that
three
two
one
fire
[Applause]
i see the bullet splits blade doesn't
fly in half which was a relief
that's almost identical damage paul
again you can see where the bullet
left a little scar running along the
side
all right good job thank you
so next up the sharpness test and for
that i'm going to turn you over to doug
late smits to see how sharp your weapons
are i will take your sword and deliver a
slash using each side of your blade and
i'll deliver a thrust
james here up first you ready let's do
it
all right james let's talk about your
sword
your edge is razor sharp on the delivery
downward it was easily
into the bag and slashed into it
your tip not coming to an exact point
but because of that edge geometry was
easy enough to thrust into this bag and
your blade
will cut good job thanks
paul you're up next you ready i'm ready
let's do this
after the way james has got that bag i'm
scared to death and
i'm just praying mine will cut
[Music]
[Music]
all right paul on the cuts over here it
starts to lacerate but not deeply enough
to go into the bag the edge geometry you
have of your tip over here isn't as
sharp as i thought it would be this did
not penetrate the bag at all when you
flipped it over
the same thing also with the other edge
it did lacerate
but not as deep
overall your blade will still cut
not as deeply yeah
next up is the kill test the cat's
bulger is a weapon that was used in
history
to kill i will take your sword and i'll
deliver lethal blows on this big carcass
james you're up first you ready let's do
it let's do this
i'm ahead at this point
that doesn't mean i'm gonna stay there
hopefully it will kill
all right james let's talk about your
blade
this section right here it nicely sliced
into the carcass it chopped through the
spine into some bone and overall
your blade will kill
thank you good job paul you ready i'm
ready let's do it
this kill test is gonna be harder on the
strength and durability of my blade than
the bullet hoping it doesn't warp and
there's a crack i'm actually very
nervous that my blade may break
[Music]
no
well paul
unfortunately your edge over here some
areas are rolled
and it hit the mark but it did not
lacerate or cut into the pig so
unfortunately your blade
will not kill
no edge at all
bladesmiths the weapons tests are now
complete the judges and i will meet you
back at the forge with our final
decision thank you
gentlemen i know you've worked very hard
on your blades but in this arena there
can only be one forged and fire champion
and that champion is
james congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion thank you paul
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut
paul
there are only six bladesmiths in the
show that can say their blades are
bulletproof you're now one of them thank
you thank you for bringing us a sword
and split a bullet i appreciate it thank
you
paul please surrender your weapon
i absolutely agree with the judge's
decision paul thanks michael i
appreciate you guys i mean i just ran
out of time there's nothing else
congratulations man thank you his blade
performed the way it's supposed to and
mine performed like a spoon
i may not be the forzan fire champion
but ladies i'm single and ready to
mingle
golly
love to dance
james congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and we'll be leaving
here with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job thank you
i'm the foreign fire champion
i will never win points for prettiness
but with the tests here or on the
battlefield it's not the pretty weapon
that wins good job i'm very lucky to be
able to make a living creating something
useful and i will use my winnings to
make more blades
you